[Music]
you know you just want to touch it you
just want it and these are all old this
is from like 87 bees if you use that old
stuff that gives it a warmer feel and
it's a feel that people might not
necessarily abuse before you know my
name is Benjamin Levin but most people
know me as a Benny Blanca I'm a producer
and songwriter and you know when I do a
song it's all about just like constantly
building up the track as it goes like
take dynamite for example Taylor Pete
[Music]
you have that you have that you're
pounding your pound and you got the
whole thing going and then when it gets
to the chorus you got that that like I
it feels like you're like floating and
then it comes back in and then you get
built up and then you're brought back
down for the verse again and then it
happens all over again and I think it
keeps it interesting for the listener
it's like a roller coaster
sometimes you spend weeks months just
getting that right and tweaking it right
and turning this harmony up and this
harmony down and like it's not so much
what you hear it's so much the feeling
it gives you as this is momentum and
it's moving
and interesting throughout the whole
song let's see this one
you got this keyboard for $25 in like
the back of this like dirty vintage tour
in that way that's not even there
anymore it just it adds a sound and an
element that it's a little bit out of
tune I'm tuning it by ear you know it
gives it a different sound that most
people aren't using today because all
their stuffs perfect pitch you know what
I want to do is I want to make it so
when someone hears it they're like what
is that what what are those sounds you
know I mean this thing is you know you
know like I just want to use I just want
to use things where when people hear
they're like I've never heard that even
if they don't like it is just that
they've been able to say I have never
heard that sound
in the Rihanna song we were like you
could go for that real big dance song
and and and that's what that's what
people would expect from her but I think
it was it was really a bold and smart
move to go for something like you know
it's like a really meaningful song you
could still dance to it but it has like
it's almost has like a toto vibe it kind
of has like that Africa vibe that
doesn't like so we wanted to bring back
it's something a little bit old-school
and nostalgic about it and make it
almost still a little wavy like the end
of the night raves where everyone's just
you know it's like it's that point in
the night where it's like you don't want
to dance so hard anymore but you just
want to really feel it